(applauding)
- What's up. I'm back with
Sarah Chalke, Kym Whitley
and a whole audience of ladies
celebrating their singlehood
give it up. (applauding)
All right, we all know we
don't need someone by our sides
to live our best lives.
And we have women in the
house seats who wanna share
how being single has
actually empowered them
in ways they could never have imagined.
So they're solo and happier than ever,
let's start with Lizzy.
What's up?
- Hi Kelly.
- [Kelly] Hi.
- You know what the best
part about being single is?
You can date yourself.
I just turned 40 in November
and I love to fly up to Seattle.
It's just like a quick 30 minute flight
and I'm in a new city,
even if it's just for the night.
I love to go and stay
at a five star hotel,
go to dinner, go
shopping, lay by the pool.
It's the perfect self care weekend.
What do you do to date yourself Kelly?
- Oh, to date myself, okay
this is gonna be real boring,
but I'm a mom of little tiny todds.
So,
I love like literally
having a glass of wine.
I put the fireplace on in my bedroom.
That's right, I work hard,
I have a fireplace in
my bedroom, that's fine.
And I read a book or I watch Netflix,
or I literally just
hang out with my girls,
I love that.
I love having just like
one or two glasses,
a respectable amount and
having fun talking (laughs)
like today. (laughter)
But I love that, what about you Sarah?
- My Oh, my favorite day would be
being outside hiking the
dogs and then doing like,
I mean bachelor ice cream and hot bath,
that would be ideal.
(laughter)
But also like you said Kelly,
hanging out with all of your girls,
like I, there's play the thing I miss most
in this pandemic, is just
having them all over inside
and chatting and hanging
out and making tea.
I think I was a barista in the past life,
so my favorite thing is I
would have my friends over
and they just all have like ridiculously,
cartoonishly large mugs,
and I'll just like keep
the hot bevs going.
- Yes, I like it.
- Nice.
- What about you Kym.
- Oh, well, that's cute what I'll saying,
but look this is the truth.
(laughter)
- Let's get some true.
- Mine is the truth.
- Yeah yeah, all right let's
get to the nitty gritty.
I have a 10 year old son I send him off,
because I'm gonna date myself.
Now what I date someone else
with my 10 year old son?
No.
So I send him off, I get some
fresh batteries for my toys.
(laughter)
(claps)
That's right, that's right, you clap.
You got just keep it real.
I get butt naked, then fire the TV.
I get one of those big,
you know those big throws and are soft
and just get, I didn't
wanna, you know the truth.
- Then you fall asleep.
- Fall asleep right in front of TV
with a chip.
(laughter)
I can't believe you all
trying to make it magical.
(laughter)
Its a wrap, butt naked with
a little, a little chip,
a little chip in my mouth.
- [Kelly] That sounds like a good time.
- That is a good time, I love it.
This is the best part,
anytime I'm at someone's house
and it's like one of my girlfriends
and like their remote
like the batteries are missing from it.
I'm like, where are they?
(laughter)
- I didn't know you knew that.
- I did that to one of my friends
and she was so embarrassed
and like not that,
whatever that sort of thing
She was like, I swear to God it not.
And I like, mm hmm
where are the batteries?
I was like.
- Oh you are good, that's why
I keep extra remotes around.
(laughter)
- She's got like 10 TVs. (laughter)
- Seven TV remotes. (laughter)
- [Kelly] Just in case, you never know.
- Oh God, oh God I love the show.
- Thank you so (laughs)
thank you so much Lizzy.
Let's hear from Shamira,
what's up Shamira.
- Hi Kelly.
- Hello.
- So the best thing and the
reason I'm thrilled to be single
is because I no longer
have to compete with a dog.
My last boyfriend had a pug
and I spent the entire relationship
pretending that I was okay
with the dog sleeping in the bed with us,
but it was anything but okay.
It was dog hair everywhere,
and the dog was kind of a
little bit of a blocker.
Anytime we will be cuddling
or snuggling up together,
the dog would nestle in between us
and like kind of pushed me away.
Like which is kind of funny
because it's a small dog.
The craziest part is
that because it's a pug,
it's not like it could
get on the bed itself.
So my ex was picking the dog up
and putting him on the bed, like for us.
So my question to you is,
what's something that you
pretended to be cool with
that you weren't cool with
while in a relationship?
- Oh.
(laughter)
- Woo.
- What is it.
- Don't be trying to come
to me saying it was you.
No, just like hot potato, its
you, its you, you go first.
- Well, nobody wants this question.
Whats yours Sarah you go first.
- Well this is something
I pretended to like
in a relationship, as I
was, I was dating this guy
who's so into music, and I love music,
but I didn't know as much,
I was young and I didn't
know as much about,
this he didn't, he invited
me to this indie concert
of this like cool indie band
at this little tiny venue
and I was like, oh my god yes,
my favorite, I'd love to.
Had no idea went right to the CD store,
bought the CD, listened to all the songs,
knew all the words, and got to the concert
and it was like a different
indie band by the same name.
(laughter)
I had no idea.
- Oh my God.
- That's awesome.
- [Shamira] Wait what is, what's yours?
- At first I was ready to go,
but think about like the,
who has that kind of time?
And even just like.
Yeah weird day.
(laughter)
- Well mine it's pretty simple.
- Okay.
- I really pretended to
enjoy dating this guy
only on Thursdays.
(laughter)
his wife hated it.
- Oh my God, no.
You are done.
- I didn't know, I didn't know.
You think it's your turn,
hot potato it's your turn.
(laughter)
- That's wrong. (laughter)
Wait my,
I well what, I dated this guy and he's,
I think because I'm a singer songwriter,
like you know if you date,
they feel like oh I'm
gonna write her a song.
And, don't. (laughter)
- Did you just say don't?
- [Kelly] Don't.
Thank you so much Shamira.
Alright, what would a single celebration
be without a gift, right,
other than just oUr present (laughter).
I've had too much.
We know Cosabella is synonymous
with high quality Italian luxury lingerie
with iconic lace and so
many fun styles and colors.
They even have great PJ's
like the Bella pajamas
and buttery soft Pima cotton
it is super soft trust me.
To help everyone in the house
seat celebrate being single,
they are giving you all a $300 gift cards
to do what it what you will.